gérard collomb qui attendait qu'ils
regardent avec beaucoup d'intensité
manière d'un conte convoiterait et mu il
est jeune mais j'ai toujours gardé voilà
gérard collomb émue aux larmes lors de
la passation de pouvoir entre françois
hollande et emmanuel macron l'image n'a
que 3 ans et pourtant il s'en est passé
des choses depuis nommé ministre de
l'intérieur gérard collomb ne sera resté
place beauvau que seize mois avant de
retourner dans son fief de lyon
aujourd'hui la rupture est
officiellement consommé entre les deux
hommes avec cet ultime affront de gérard
collomb une alliance au deuxième tour
des élections municipales avec les
républicains pour faire barrage aux
verts tout proche du pouvoir dans la
troisième ville de france
en quoi consiste la core précisément
gérard collomb renonce à briguer la
métropole de lyon en échange le candidat
de droite sur la ville s'efface derrière
le poulain de gérard collomb c'est un
moment qui peut surprendre car nous
venons de familles politiques
différentes pour l'avenir de lyon il
faut une majorité stable pour
reconstruire une ville qui va beaucoup
souffrir
qui aurait cru il y a encore dix ans que
ce poids lourd du socialisme aurait
penché à droite
pas grand monde cette trahison ne passe
pas et le couperet tombe rapidement
yann cucherat le poulain de gérard
collomb père l'investiture et l'hérault
m
le parti présidentiel se retrouve donc
sans candidat officiel dans une ville
qui était il ya peu à la fois le berceau
et le bastion du maquereau nisme en
choisissant de s'allier avec les
républicains sous la bénédiction de
laurent wauquiez
plutôt que de vrais au rassemblement de
notre famille politique gérard collomb
franchi une ligne rouge
je ne peux l'accepter il a perdu les
élections municipales au premier tour et
je trouve que ce choix politique le père
dans le champ politique dans cette
attitude
il se perd lui même c'est un jour bien
sombre pour notre vie politique locale
ceci montre à quel point gérard collomb
est isolé acculé pour sauver sa peau
coûte que coûte à coopérer avec ses
ennemis politiques de toujours c'est la
pire image qu'un homme politique puisse
donner ce qui effraie le plus dans la
sphère présidentielle
que d'autres suivent l'exemple c'est
déjà le cas à perpignan où une
conseillère municipale 10e sur la liste
et l'hérault m assume aujourd'hui
soutenir
louis aliot candidat du rassemblement
national alors que le candidat du parti
présidentiel s'est retirée pour faire
barrage à l'ancien compagnon de marine
le pen à paris des rumeurs font état
d'une possible alliance entre agnès
buzyn ancien ministre de la santé des
manuels macron et rachida dati candidate
des républicains
l'objectif serait de contrer anne
hidalgo candidate socialiste maire
sortante est arrivé en tête du premier
tour des municipales à paris
mais pour l'heure il n'en est rien en
tout cas pas officiellement il n'y aura
aucun accord d'appareils
nous aurons une tête de liste dans
chaque arrondissement pas de fusion avec
lrm dans le 5e arrondissement les
parisiens veulent un changement profond
à paris ce confinement a accentué cette
volonté de changement tout abstention
dispersion des voix favorisera
l'immobilisme et même le déclin de paris
des alliances incohérente qui pourrait
avoir de vives répercussions sur un la
crédibilité de la république en marche
on se souvient du modem qui avaient opté
pour une stratégie similaire aux
municipales de 2008 le parti de françois
bayrou fois fini par le payer tant dans
les urnes que dans l'opinion la
république en marchant parti qui se dit
ni de droite ni de gauche
si cette formule a fait le succès d'
emmanuel macron en 2017
elle semble aujourd'hui lui joué
quelques tours